syntactically awesome stylesheets or
sass is a language that can extend your
css with super powers
modern uis are extremely complex and if
you attempt to build one with plain css
you'll find yourself repeating yourself
often sas comes to the rescue by
providing a compiler
that allows us to write style sheets in
a completely different language well two
different languages to be exact the
original
indented syntax that you find in dot
sass files removes the syntactic salt of
semicolons and curly braces
[Applause]
[Music]
but the more popular version is the
superset syntax that you find in scss
files
here you can write regular css then
extend it with additional bonus features
as needed
sas has been around for nearly 15 years
and one of its original killer features
was variables
use a dollar sign to name a variable
then reference it somewhere else in your
code
now if that value ever changes you only
have to update one line of code css
introduced its own native variables a
few years ago
but the advantages don't stop there
killer feature number two is nesting in
many cases
classes are used as name spaces which
means they're often duplicated over and
over again we can avoid this duplication
by nesting styles inside the parent by
default these classes will apply to
descendant elements or
they can be applied to a direct sibling
by using the ampersand which
itself is a tool that tells sas to
combine the parent selector with the
nested child selector
now one other issue with css is that
you'll often find yourself including
a similar group of styles on multiple
classes mix-ins allow you to encapsulate
a group of styles
then apply those styles anywhere in your
code using the include keyword
mixons can also take arguments to create
a large number of similar classes
programmatically
like a bunch of different colored
buttons for example in addition
sas provides a whole suite of tools to
help you write more programmatic code
use if or else in a mixin for
conditional logic or create an array of
values with a variable then loop over
them with each
and you might even extract all this
logic into a reusable function
or sas might already have a built-in
function for you ready to go
if you need to adjust a color you can
use the lighten or darken functions to
adjust a color by a predictable value
when you're finished building a
beautiful ui
the compiler will take your code and
convert it into valid css that can run
in the browser
this has been sas in 100 seconds but
before you go here's one more bonus pro
tip when working with nested code it can
sometimes be hard to figure out
exactly which set of braces you're
inside of in vs code enable the bracket
pair colorizer extension to give each
set of braces their own unique color
make sure to hit the like button if you
want to see more short videos like this
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one